pour les candidats connus du grand
public les parrainages ne sont qu'une
formalité pour les autres moins connus
c'est un véritable parcours du
combattant alors parrainage le système
est-il archaïque c'est la question qu'on
vous a posé qu'on vous pose toujours
d'ailleurs sur le compte un télégramme
verte et france vous pouvez toujours
réagir et c'est l'objet de notre face à
face
avec nous pour en parler pierre
fred-lille billets mer et l'air de dreux
bonsoir faire frédéric merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau
également denis sied slick porte-parole
dmd ligue zemmour est responsable
justement des parrainages bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous alors première
question pierre frédéric billet vous est
harcelé entre nîmes et à l'image de ce
maire de l'emitt ça doit être encore
pire puisque dreux c'est encore plus
grand
non non je suis par céline ou raison
très simple si je suis encarté chez les
nerfs et tout le monde sait que j'irai
parrainer le candidat des républicains
book je suis pas du tout à celui des
tentatives gentilly plutôt à bika
j'étais au congrès des maires très
récemment et et quelques candidats que
j'ai pu rencontrer ici la norme dont
jean lassalle ont dit toute l'amitié qui
me portait à l'occasion ses demandes de
parrainage mais voilà c'est sympathique
mais moi ya pas trop de difficultés
alors le maire de limoux d'un nous
décrit quand même son malaise il
aimerait bien parrainer un ou plusieurs
candidats d'ailleurs mais il ne veut
surtout pas on comprend être associés
aux partis politiques de la personne
qu'ils parrainent puisque il dit en gros
parrainage égale associations partis
politiques il dit que ce serait mal vu
de ses administrés d'ailleurs ça a été
le cas à l'époque on va justement voir
une première réaction télégramme qui en
rapport avec cela celle de sébastien
regarder sébastien qui nous dit c'est
surtout la levée de anonymat qui
perturbe les parrainages 2006 et smic ça
c'est un vrai danger notamment peut-être
pour le candidat que vous soutenez eric
zemmour sept associations partis
politiques
associés à ce maire et les parrainages
anonyme ça aurait peut-être été un
meilleur plan pour vous oui absolument
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites je partage tout à fait la vie de
l'internaute qui vient d'être donné le
fait que l'anonymat était élevé c'est
une loi qui a été votée à l'époque de
françois hollande est une véritable
catastrophe démocratique et vraiment je
pèse mes mots on est dans une situation
où il ya des candidats à 4 % dans les
sondages qui sont absolument certain
d'avoir leurs promesses de parrainages
et d'en avoir trois quatre mille benoît
hamon avait je crois quatre mille
promesses de parrainages et 4000
parrainage effectif avant la
présidentielle et d'autres qui sont à 15
16% et sans jugement de valeur
d'ailleurs sur les idées en tant que tel
mais qui représente donc quelque chose
qui ne sont pas assurés d'avoir ses
promesses de parrainages d'avoir ces
parrainages et donc de pouvoir concourir
je pense qu'on arrive à une limite de ce
système il est évidemment bon qu'il y
ait une limite donnée par l'état qu'il y
ait un contrôle pour éviter les
candidatures fantaisistes mais la levée
de l'anonymat c'est quelque part la mort
d'une partie de notre démocratie parce
que beaucoup de maires aujourd'hui se
sente sous pression et le témoignage
était très très bien le très moyen le
témoignage du maire qui a parlé dans le
sujet précédent explique très bien qu'il
a peur des réactions de ces que ses
administrés éventuellement parfois même
de menaces sur les subventions ce sont
des choses qu'on voit sur le terrain de
menaces d'exclusion du parti donc la
levée de l'anonymat pour moi c'est une
très mauvaise nouvelle et pour la
démocratie française aussi pierre
frédéric billet c'est vrai que ça
favorise plutôt les les parties dont
vous faites partie les républicains mais
que pensez vous de ce que vient de dire
monsieur sy et slick c'est vrai que les
petits candidats il ya un problème quand
même de démocratie quand on s'imagine
que marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon ou
eric zemmour je vais pas vous faire
voilà le calcul de ce qu'ils
représentent dans les sondages mais
quand même ça pèse assez lourd à eux
trois ils sont même pas sûrs d'avoir
leur parrainage
est-ce que vous adhérez il n'y a pas un
problème démocratique comme on le dit
monsieur si oui alors deux points de
précisions ce n'est pas un parrainage
c'est une présentation du candidat donc
c'est pas parce qu'on fait un parrainage
que vous soutenez être candidat vous
pouvez présenter un candidat dans le
cadre de gérer la diversité démocratique
qu'elle pluralité puisse exprimer ça
c'est la première chose un point de
décider aussi est ce que monsieur disait
est un peu inexactes en fait l'anonymat
n'a pas été levé par l'ine jospin en
réalité avant il y avait un tirage au
sort des 500 nour qui était publié dans
le journal officiel maintenant
l'intégralité et ça voilà
et donc c'est l'intégralité maintenant
qui est publié avant il y avait un
tirage au sort il y avait 500 donc été
tiré au sort pas candidat et qui était
publié donc c'est vrai que ça va changer
un petit peu la donne maintenant il faut
voir aussi que les maires par haine de
moins en moins on est passé de 34 me l'a
36 à 2,36 1034 mis dans cinq ans il ya
une dégradation
parce que les maires ruraux n'ont pas
forcément toujours peur de prendre
position mais simplement ils se sentent
un peu abandonné quand vous êtes maire
d'un village de 500 habitants dans la
corrèze
heureusement qu'elle sous préfet dans le
coin qui essaie de faire ce qu'il peut
mais globalement ils se sentent
délaissés dont quand vous voyez les
candidats on a vu lors des déjeuners
mort venir chez-nous vareuse des maires
ruraux aussi eu des poussées bon des
fois ils pensent comme eux mais oui ils
veulent pas s'afficher sans délaisser et
puis ils ont l'impression que l'équipe
de zemmour disent qu'ils entendent tous
les cinq ans tous les six ans et que
voilà il ya une sorte de lassitude
maintenant la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est comment peut-on faire
respirer notre démocratie plus
facilement pour les candidats sérieux
voilà donc il ya eu des réformes
proposées il ya le comité balladur qui
en 2007 a fait des propositions là
dessus le comité jose parle qui avait
fait aussi des propositions pour passer
d'un parrainage d'élus est l'image
citoyens c'est pas inintéressant faut en
parler mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il faut renouveler cet accès à la
présidentielle on a toujours autant de
candidats depuis 14 ans nés entre 12 et
16 candidats donc ça respire mais
certains politiques ont des grosses
difficultés pour avant l'ampleur des
dommages justement vous parlez de ce
parrainage citoyen proposé par la
commission jose pas en 2012 bastien la
chaux de la france a soumises aimerait
bien leur voir naître l'air voir naître
cette proposition mais il dit il m'a
même accro lui préfère que les
candidatures soient filtrées par les
élus et par les banques parce que d'une
certaine manière ça c'est moi qu'elle
rajoute m'enfin ça les arrange est ce
que vous êtes d'accord de nice y
explique avec le fait que voilà les
grands partis notamment emmanuel macron
n'a pas nécessairement intérêt à voir
les parrainages devenir tout simplement
citoyen en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que je vais répondre immédiatement
votre question mais je partage ce que
vient de dire monsieur le maire le le
parrainage c'est d'abord et avant tout
une présentation donc c'est un acte
citoyen et démocratique que chacun doit
pouvoir comprendre et à ce titre il ne
doit pas être considérée comme un
soutien je voyais bien que c'est le cas
sur le terrain mais du coup j'espère que
monsieur le maire va faire jouer son
sens démocratique comme son candidat
aura nécessairement les parrainages en
parrainant la candidature d'eric zemmour
boutade mise à part sur les parrainages
citoyens mais moi qui me plus que les 20
plus qu'un autre parce que il est
essentiel que tous ces candidats que
vous avez cités et d'ailleurs vous voyez
moi je soutiens eric zemmour mais je
trouverais ça proprement scandaleux que
jean luc mélenchon marine le pen
n'obtiennent pas leur parrainage il
représente quelque chose dans la vie
politique française on peut être
d'accord on peut ne pas être d'accord
mais il faut qu'ils puissent se
soumettre au suffrage des français
vraiment je crois que c'est fondamental
et donc je ne suis pas convaincu que le
parrainage citoyen qui ont les contours
en plus sont très peu déterminée soit
nécessairement la solution en revanche
imaginer revenir ou en tout cas arrivé
parce que monsieur le maire avait raison
c'est un système qui n'a jamais
véritablement été appliquée un système
de parrainage de 500 pourquoi pas même
600 signatures mais avec un anonymat qui
soit pleinement garantis je crois que ce
serait un bon moyen de garder pour les
mères cette prérogative qui est
importante qui est la leur c'est pas la
peine de leur retirer des prérogatives
supplémentaires
ils ont déjà beaucoup souffert pendant
ce quinquennat mais aussi un moyen de
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent sans
avoir peur des pressions notamment
subventions ce que je trouve proprement
scandaleux par une équipe de souhaite
alors évidemment la question que je
brûle dans vis de vous poser depuis
d'ailleurs le début de ce débat est ce
que eric zemmour il les a séparés nage
c'est 500 parrainages non alors à
laquelle je parle nous n'avons pas réuni
500 promesses de parrainages d'autant
plus qu'en réalité on parle de 500
promesses mais il faut 700 ou 800
promesses pour s'assurer d'avoir les 500
parrainages puisque certains maires
peuvent signer une promesse et ne pas
renvoyer au conseil constitutionnel
le document qui avient seule une valeur
juridique donc nous n'avons pas à
l'heure actuelle 500 promesses de
parrainages et encore moins 700 vous
l'avez compris en revanche nous sommes
plutôt confiants alors à laquelle je
parle sur le fait que nous pourrons les
obtenir mais pour ça quelle gabegie
d'énergie il faut mettre en place une
machine structurellement
organisée avec des centaines et des
centaines de personnes sur le terrain
avec des cellules de phoning c'est c'est
une gabegie d'énergie qui pourrait je
crois être mise ailleurs pierre frédéric
gay votre sentiment quand vous entendez
notre responsable des parrainages d'eric
zemmour voilà nos gars c'est pas sûr
qu'ils les aient alors on sait que
marine le pen dit la même chose ça fait
plusieurs élections maintenant
notre sentiment là-dessus
oui alors techniquement faut aussi
expliquer qu'on a des promesses de
parrainages et quand on fait les
parrainages peut être envoyé dix
semaines avant le premier tour et
quelques semaines avant le premier tour
donc c'est une fenêtre assez courte donc
c'est pour ça que souvent on prévoit
plus de parrainage parce qu'il ya de la
perte au lit ça c'est la première chose
la seconde chose effectivement on peut
se poser la question des parrainages
parce qu'il a faim au niveau là dessus
en même temps il faut comprendre que les
parrainages en charge du clonage c'est
aussi la découverte des territoires de
france c'est aussi l'occasion des des
comités en place d'aller voir les maires
même si des fois iralde en découvrant de
voir quelqu'un de discuter etc et puis
je me souviens dans le passé que la
famille le pen avait largement utilisé
cet argument pour faire de la boue c'est
dire que
voilà pour sauver la france les des
parrainages et qu'ils étaient contre le
système etc c'est une vieille ficelle je
dis pas que monsieur zemmour fait ça
parce que voilà mais en tout cas c'est
aussi l'occasion de mettre la lumière
sur un candidat c'est ça qui empêche
eric zemmour justement de se présenter
officiellement pour l'instant au
contraire comme le dit le puits afin de
réveiller il profite de cette tribune
est et de cet éclairage est l'occasion
de se mettre en avant non je crois pas
monsieur zemmour
prendre les décisions qu'il veut prendre
tout seul et je crois pas que les
parrainages j'ai eu un impact quelconque
sur la date de candidature qui l'a
arrêté en revanche ce qui est certain
c'est qu'on se sera dimanche
toute façon au point où on en est que ce
soit demain mercredi au dimanche on est
dans une zone restreinte on sait que
c'est pour très bientôt on a tous
beaucoup patienter je peux vous dire que
c'est pour bientôt je vais à paris le
jour même non je pense que eric zemmour
il il ne joue pas particulièrement de
cet argument d'ailleurs nous on a
commencé à s'activer avant même que lui
est une implication quelconque dans la
campagne c'est à dire que nous on a
monté une structure pour rechercher les
parrainages qui après c'est vraiment
professionnaliser qui est montée en
compétence qui à qui et qui est vraiment
devenu à la hauteur d'une campagne
présidentielle sans qu'eric zemmour
n'intervienne alors maintenant c'est un
peu un peu différent il est au courant
de nos avancées idées au courant de nos
démarches mais je ne crois pas que ce
soit ça qui est un impact sur la date de
candidature maintenant maintenant je
voudrais vraiment solennellement faire
un appel à tous les maires qui nous
écoutent pas rennais qui vous voulez
pour de préférence eric zemmour
parrainer qui vous voulez mais parrainer
c'est vraiment un acte citoyen je pense
que tous les citoyens même si parfois
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué peuvent
comprendre que c'est un acte
démocratique de parrainer on présente un
candidat on ne décide pas de voter pour
lui on le présentait donc tous ceux qui
veulent nous soutenir et qui soutiennent
notre démarche peuvent aller sur le site
les amis d'eric zemmour point fr onglet
paris
en tout cas eric zemmour ce n'est pas le
seul
araméen pour ces candidatures il y en a
un autre nicolas dupont aignan qui a du
mal à trouver c'est signatures comme il
ya cinq ans d'ailleurs je me proposais
côté le patron de débouler france très
clairement j'ai fait un appel solennel
au maire aujourd'hui je peux
manquer les 500 parrainages à quelques
signatures près je ne voudrais pas finir
à 480 et et au jour d'aujourd'hui je le
dis très clairement s'il n'y a pas un
soutien à parrainage des maires je
risque de ne pas pouvoir être candidat
bon voilà il y en a des appels ce soir
pierre un frédéric billet vous pas de
problème du côté lr évidemment il ya un
ancrage d'élus locaux assez
impressionnant il facilite la récolte
des signatures vous préfériez par vous
justement donné le parrainage un petit
candidat dont on vient de parler plutôt
que d'assurer le coup pour l'un des des
poulains dont on connaît pas encore le
nom d'ailleurs chez les républicains oui
oui c'est une question ou exposer
simplement vous savez les républicains
c'est le parti qui a la plus grande
assistaient les temps rien de ce mode
territoire les on a beaucoup à gagner
beaucoup d'élections on a renouvelé nos
présidents de région les élections
municipales ont été un beau succès donc
il est vrai que les parrainages des
républicains c'est aussi une grande
force pour notre candidat ça montre que
tous les territoires de france sont
représentées et moi très engagé auprès
des candidats répondent aux futures
présidentielles j'ai retrouvé mon
parrainage ou candidat ou à la candidate
des républicains vous auriez plutôt
intérêt quand même à ce qu'eric zemmour
puisse finalement se présenter n'est ce
pas ce qui aurait peut-être le mérite de
beats diluer certaines voix à droite et
de voir peut-être un nouveau poulain
tournée
au pays magique des quads bourbon des
stratégies bien sûr tout ça tout ça dans
les tuyaux simplement quelqu'un déjà ce
stade on n'est pas déjà dans ses
stratégies tout de même sérieusement oui
c'est oui certainement mais si vous
voulez des nouveaux bien que monsieur
dupont-aignan a beaucoup de difficultés
parce que l'on est en réalité il vit en
concurrence avec eric zemmour avec
madame le pen et la course aux
parrainages devient plus compliqué parce
que il ya un nouveau acteur sur le
terrain qui grosso modo n'est pas si
loin politiquement qui représente
quelque chose et donc des parrainages se
disperser entre ces trois candidats en
rajouter d'autres d'ailleurs donc ça
complexifie la chose maintenant je pense
que eric zemmour si les candidats dont
les prochains jours peut-être demain il
aura ses parrainages c'est une
difficulté en plus mais je pense qu'il
les aura parce que au bout du compte
souvenons nous des présidente d'élection
il ya des mères qui ont donné leurs
parrainages aux animaux parce qu'il
voulait que tel ou tel candidat puisse
même s'ils n'étaient pas d'accord avec
lui pouvoir pouvoir se présenter aux
élections donc c'est difficile c'est
compliqué quand on se lance dans une
telle campagne qu'on est un tout nouveau
candidat qu'on n'a pas de parti
politique derrière soi c'est difficile
mais je le répète ça m'a permis aussi de
se frotter au terrain de voir un peu ce
qu'est ce que la france parce que vu
pareil c'est une chose les buts du
territoire et des fois d'humilier très
très loin
de nier le fait que clairement d'accord
avec cette analyse c'est vrai qu'à une
dispersion peut-être entre des candidats
qui se ressemblent vous êtes d'accord
avec ça il ya évidemment du fait déjà
que seuls 30 % des mères en moyenne par
une fois que ces 35 % aux dernières
présidentielles et les prévisions sont
en baisse pour celle ci 1 un vivier de
par un potentiel qui est déjà restreint
ajoutez à ça le fait que les grands
candidats en tout cas les candidats deux
grands partis même s'ils sont des petits
candidats parfois dans les sondages
obtiennent trois à quatre mille
signatures ça restreint grandement le
champ oui il y as je pense une
concurrence dans les trois candidatures
dit du corps national entre madame le
pen monsieur dupont-aignan et monsieur
zemmour sur le terrain des parrainages
mais qui a donné lieu et c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs à une notion que
que j'ai construite que que je n'avais
pas idée dont je n'avais pas idée c'est
la notion de parrainage utile c'est le
vote utile mais le parrainage utile je
n'en avais jamais entendu parler il ya
beaucoup de mères qui me disent bas moi
j'ai toujours parrainé marine le pen
mais cette fois ci je pense que monsieur
zemmour est mieux placé pour gagner et
donc c'est à lui que je vais donner ma
signature est donc cette cette notion de
stratégie dans les parrainages allait
bien prise en compte par les élus que
nous avons d'ailleurs grand plaisir à
les rencontrer sur le terrain même si
nous préférerions que leur anonymat soit
préservé
et le mot de la fin il faut la réformer
7 il faut le réformer ce système de
parrainage oui certes est certainement
qu'il faut réformer c'est maintenant
qu'il faut imaginer mais ce sera
s'accompagnera d'autres réformes
certainement aussi sur le poids de
l'assemblée nationale il ya un vrai
sujet là dessus on voit que l'assemblée
en train d'écrire en termes d' influence
ça devient de plus en plus une salle
d'enregistrement peut-être un
rééquilibrage entre le présent
république et le ministre
bref il ya du pain sur la planche après
les élections présidentielles et
notamment les parrainages ou le système
d'accès à l'élection suprême il faudra
déménager tout ça très fortement merci
en tout cas tous les deux pierre
frédéric billets adonis et c'est d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france